[Musique]
moore
moi c'est fifo photographe et directeur
artistique depuis plus de quinze ans
entre autres dans le milieu urbain le
rap ou connaît surtout sur mon travail
sur les pochettes de beaucoup d'artistes
plus que c'est un milieu assez petit là
je me retrouve dans une pollution
d'avoir pratiquement beau c'est que tout
le monde essentiellement la scène
parisienne à la base maintenant ça fait
quelque temps que je travaille beaucoup
avec les marseillais aux six voix jude
soprano et sur paris sur les plus
anciens on peut parler de secteur à pacy
doc gynéco et aujourd'hui tu as toute la
nouvelle génération est ce qu'on appelle
la dreale aussi donc nouveaux artistes
comme gazeau des artistes plus confirmés
comme lignot et
ma touche c'est la mise en scène c'est
créer des mises en scène assez hors
normes entre guillemets et qui essaye de
casser un peu les codes des pochettes de
rap de mecs en bas de leur bloc même si
j'aime bien faire ce type de shooting
mais en tout cas dans les pochettes qui
ressortent ces derniers temps c'est
beaucoup de mises en scène où j'aime
bien aussi allié des éléments qui vont
pas forcément ensemble faire une oeuvre
assez folle quoi voilà on m'a appelé
pour
jouer mon propre rôle c'est une espèce
de mise en abyme
j'ai capté plutôt les pet society kawa
non c'est l'inversé ok explique moi ce
que tu veux faire j'ai toujours ce souci
du détail qui est devenu d'ailleurs un
challenge dans cette série qui est
toujours de mélanger la réalité et la
fiction est de faire participer à la
série les vrais protagonistes du vrai
milieu du vrai monde du rap et je prends
beaucoup de plaisir à faire participer
aussi des techniciens des personnalités
du monde du rap alors parfois ça va être
un tourneur photographe réalisateur
aujourd'hui afficheront il ya aussi
screech qui est un célèbre choeur de
deux clips de rap et je trouve que c'est
ça qui fait que valider est ancré dans
cette réalité c'est qu'on fait
participer les vraies personnes
on
va en parler
et j'ai joué avec rohff ya une scène qui
est très très forte avec rohff
c'est un dieu c'est sa toiture en jetons
câline termine la discussion sont
attachés et assume je pense que
je pense ou des
achats douanes leïla et nos matchs à
douala madarassou noir
de tourner avec rohff c'est quand même
quelque chose tu vois parce que erreur
fait partie comme ma carrière comme
plein d'autres de ces gens qui ont fait
le rap que moi j'ai grandi avec sa
musique laser
sur cette saison de la participation de
rohff était prévu est écrit en amont
parce que il avait déjà fait savoir sur
la saison une qu'il avait envie d'être
dans la saison et puis c'est quelque
chose d'important pour un rappeur
d'aller prendre le risque en fait de
faire un acteur
donc moi je suis très respectueux de
chacun des guest chacun des rappeurs qui
osent venir jouer un rôle même s'ils
jouent leur propre rôle tout ça est
quand même de l'acting et c'est pas
simple c'est pas donné à tout le monde
et puis je suis aussi très reconnaissant
parce qu'ils apportent avec eux à chaque
fois
leur image ils apportent avec eux leur
public et cette série elle elle est
devenue ce qu'elle est en grande partie
grâce à eux pour être très honnête mais
choix sur les guest sont aussi orientés
par le public c'est à dire je cherche à
faire plaisir au public et je me pose la
question de savoir quel rappeur qu'elles
baissent le public aimerait voir et puis
alors il ya ce que j'aimerais avoir qui
sont pas dispo il ya ceux qui semblent
pas de faire l'acteur il ya ceux qui
aimeraient des rôles plus gros et puis
au milieu de toutes ces équations bas on
trouve quelques solutions qui sont les
gaz qui sont dans la série moi en tant
que ça et doux c'est toujours pareil
toujours impressionné c'est pas très
longtemps qu'on est dans ce milieu là
donc de voir que non et re principaux
d'une série dans laquelle autour de nous
il ya des gens qu'on a écouté en
grandissant
c'était très très content parce que j'ai
retrouvé une grande amie à moi qui ai
amel bent j'étais contente de voir voilà
hamel qui qui valide laetitia là à
travers cette petite scène
franchement respect pour ce que tu as
fait hier soir ma soeur j'ai kiffé et je
pense que toutes les meufs qui fait
merci merci beaucoup franchement venant
tosan touché en plus je suis pas fan on
voit là les intérêts présentation n ya
plus besoin de monde la connaît
maintenant j'ai aussi joué avec dinos
donc s'acheter est contente en fait en
tout cas on s'est croisés pour une
petite scène et aux dinos à écouter
ouais je l'écouté devrait franchement
l'occuper
je mens je me surpris
il y avait pas mal d'artistes de toutes
les générations en passant de francs
glee chat gazeaux qui est sorti
récemment pour ceux qui écoutent du rap
moi j'ai vu ses flux sans casquette il
ya un mystérieux
snipers purée c'est la mrc mon enfance
il y avait un parterre incroyable comme
d'habitude en vrai ça devient un peu la
marque de fabrique de valider de ramener
des célébrités qui jouent leur propre
rôle et qu'ils participent flora
tombeuse on espère
[Musique]